nicht nach opfer ich habe überall so
viele bücher ungehindert und ich habe
keines dieser bücher ist jemals
reingeguckt ich sitze seit zwei stunden
und mache
luftpolsterfolie kaputt
hätte dass wir den während der
unterricht schon auf chrome ist euer
lehrer sagt sofortige portocolom
während der pause dann gefühlte man drei
gottesdienste stattfinden eine formel 1
meisterschaft sieben sportturniere 18
orten und raketenstart zum mars sind
mittlerweile drei tagen nicht mehr
duschen
wir mittlerweile diesem punkt also
kommen wo ich wirklich sagen kann wenn
ich allein da auf der welt wäre würde
ich gar nicht mehr duschen herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge durch
einen koch hex mit live acts mit wo
kraft anstatt dass ihr versucht mit dem
haltegriff des messers zu schneiden
neben einfach die schafe seite
verbessert
wenn die leute die ab 2003 geworden sind
mir richtig leid
wir hatten corona lockdown den gute
achtzehnten geburtstag weggenommen und
jetzt könnt ihr nicht war autofahren
warten preise geist kann teuer sind
ja wenigstens habt ihr bock
sieht übrigens nichts schlimmeres als
preisschilder die man nicht richtig
abziehen kann
keine ahnung was mit ihm los
mein nächster machen in welche sachen
[Musik]
wassermelonen ist die beste frucht der
welt ganz kurzes update über fahrstuhl
[Musik]
fährt wieder
verständlich richtig trittin hat ihr
leben hängt einfach an so einem seil nur
wenn man zu vollstrecken zu laufen ich
darf euch jetzt so spannend sind
aktivität des heutigen blogs begrüßen
und luca stellen die waschmaschine an
dafür machen wir welche rein
und machen die waschmaschine an
das ist dass die polizei es sind was ich
hier gesehen
links ich dachte immer dass
immobilienberater einem mobilfunk
verträge günstiger anbieten
wegen mobil
hat mal kurzzeitig für seinen coolen job
machen
[Applaus]
ihr müll sieht rot
es macht er mittlerweile auch einfach
keinen sinn mehr
einfach es ist die hunderasse der welt
normalerweise mag ich briefe von
zuschauer nie irgendein video a war dir
jemand geschrieben dass ich einen geilen
arsch habe
doch gesagt habe ich
es wird mal wieder gekocht
wir gucken jetzt tommy und dann gehen
wir schlafen bild morgen
extra eine kamera vorher eingestellt
damit die weitere tagesplanung für heute
wird übrigens sein dass wir gleich vier
fette tüten an hilfs sachen für ukraine
flüchtlinge spenden werden dann muss ich
bilder von peyton wieder machen und dann
fahren wir an stand da freue ich mich
schon sehr drauf ist das kalt und ich
weiß nicht ob man sich als kalt in
aschach ich bin jetzt aber erstmal
muss ich mit den jetzt erstmal so einen
deal aushandeln weil ich habe drei
monate hier trainieren werde ich gar
nicht kenne eigentlich ganz gut 29 euro
pro woche
das sind 120 euro monat das sind 360
euro für drei monate heute ist sie
übrigens die freiwillige bürger zu
besuchen jim werde ich wieder hier bin
und einfach viel zu heißen einfach
vorsichtsmaßnahmen mir geht es einfach
nur richtig schiffen
drei stunden unterwegs davon war ich
jedoch nur eineinhalb stunden im gym
wisst ihr was sich die anderen
anderthalb schon gemacht habe richtig
die person gesucht die ihr fahrrad an
mein fahrrad angekettet hat wie blöd
kannst du sein ich werde mich dass wir
unter zeitlichen gründen ca 70 teams
gedreht hat indem übrig die kommentare
und blogs und immer lustiger als lästig
doch selbst wie viele texte gedreht hat
sich weg war
nicht tanken gerade
230 spazieren
ich muss passen
im sala bimbam badu sala dem glaube
liebe hoffnung alles geht gut
gefundenen schätze hier abgeben
wir geben dem müll einen korb dick an
welchem team das team mit so
was ich verstehe nicht wieso wir
schwimmen kann
ja das ist auch logisch aber ich weiß
auch nicht wieso das ist der stand von
dem ich geredet hatte
ich frage mich wer vor seinem schiff
dann schlussendlich steht und sich
denken die arme dort ist eine beate
normale menschen laufen so durch den
sonst hätten läuft wie der schildkröten
weil sie keinen sand in den schuhen
haben bis sie am strand hängen gesetzt
und ich muss sagen ich finde es jetzt
nicht so imposant aber
ich habe imposant wie nennt man muschel
mit erkältung
also ich bin ganz ehrlich
dem ist echt noch nicht gesagt werden
also man besser für mich aber ich würde
meinen bestechen
wie wärs wenn ich jetzt einfach mal ein
handy nehmen könnten oft eins drauflegen
und dann würdest du akku von mir
bekommen ich verstehe warum apple das
nicht ausgemacht hat nach besser aus da
oben sieht einfach so aus wie wenn man
bei lego nicht mehr den passenden stein
hatte
in der seine kraft zu denken
darf nicht durch schön einer großen
talente weißt du
wie nennt man eine ente zwischen zwei
bergen
talente
talentmanagement jutta stopka von deinem
zuwinkt
kein problem eigentlich sollte ich
eintritt nehmen für meine blogs so geld
nehmen dass man sich das angucken darf
15 euro oder so
dann könnte ich mir um den lottoschein
leisten
er wurde übrigens geschrieben das
einfach was wahrscheinlicher ist auf dem
weg zum lotto laden zu sterben als im
lotto zu gewinnen das heißt ein großes
risiko schon crazy dass so ein hund
einfach sein so sagt gail das ziemlich
schmal zweck der läuft
das ist die perfekte
kleine werde wir haben die quelle
ist einfach
da jetzt keine welle
wie heißt die clique von dem fluss hier
dir deine sorgen einwerfen kannst du da
rein bitte
ich bin für jeden dreck zu haben also
für dich
jetzt kriegt also viel hätte den
kommentaren war ich aber so gemein zu
töten wenn ich aber nur den block
[Musik]
solche schilder habe ich halt nie
verstanden was sie in die richtung
nichts von der sache ja drauf steht
sagen mir was außer wasser oder
hausnummer 11 was heißt jetzt hv
08 10 14 v
wo wohnst du den weißen aus amberg
einfach fett straße sind jetzt wieder zu
hause spielen gesellschaftsspiele
pudding essen erdbeeren und sahne sind
wir hier ist einfach kein aufgefallen
dass man ein stativ und ich meine schere
volk sondern passen gehen beide zum teil
silber und schwarz und guten bund
falls ihr euch fragen warum hat den
rotes kleid dann gehen wir irgendwo noch
hinein ich muss jetzt um halb elf noch
bilder noch tiefgarage machen
jetzt aufgefallen dass ich überhaupt
kein ende für den heutigen blog gedreht
habe deswegen zschau